we are stationed in Indianapolis Indiana
today I'll be on the air once again to
start the combine coverage on the NFL
Network on-field drills coverage at 9:00
a.m. Eastern Time on Friday and a man
who knows so much about all of these
kids college kids no more getting set to
take the next step into the next level
of the National Football League college
football sideline reporter for Fox
Sports and writer for Sports Illustrated
who wrote a great piece about ten freaky
athletic kids you might not know are
gonna jump out of the building this week
he is Bruce Feldman how are you Bruce
I'm doing great rich my favorite time of
the year seems to be combine time is
that run well I mean it's interesting
because now you're watching kids that
you have learned about and covered quite
a bit at the collegiate level go to the
next step who seeing kids that that
succeed at the next level is their based
on your reporting and seeing in an
experience that you think the makeup
wise knowing can succeed at the next
level is that is there a formula from
what you've seen firsthand you know I
don't think there is beyond this one big
thing that this goes back to you know
writing a recruiting book and spending a
year inside a college football program
but decade-plus ago was you better have
somebody who loves football because
ultimately you know that's to me the
biggest thing if you have somebody who
has all the talent in the world and is
one of those combine freak guys but they
just either aren't really competitive or
aren't really tough as you all know I
mean it's such a grind that the margin
between your athleticism and everybody
else's is not gonna is nowhere near what
it is in the college game in the college
game with its wide hat wider hash marks
that kind of can help create that I mean
sometimes you're out there against
walk-ons and kids who you know probably
wouldn't be playing unless you know
maybe it was an injury or whatever so
you better have somebody who really
loves it and it's really tough I think
those are the to me the biggest factors
but just you know talking about how far
they've come I remember I did a
quarterback look you know four years ago
and I remember seeing Josh Rosen as a
junior in high school you know and he
was a fantastic talent then but you
would see a little bit of the maybe no
filter kind of stream of
just as how you'd respond to stuff but
at the same token he was you know 16
years old I'm not sure how I don't think
I would have handled things that well if
somebody put a microphone in front of me
and you know made me think I was great
when I was 16 years old how I would
respond well but that and that was gonna
be my next question so you let me write
to it because when you talk about love
of football and wondering if it is there
based on the talent level that you have
seen and how that those might not be you
know easily combined based on how great
he looks on the field and how poor
apparently he has an attitude towards
loving football Josh Rosen is the
biggest conundrum I've seen in quite
some time and you had a great tweet this
week that I quoted on the show just the
other day about about his toughness why
do you think Rosen still has this stigma
about him do you think it is accurate
coming into this combine I don't think
it's really accurate I don't know like
the dirt I think there's a separation
between what durability is and toughness
because you can have plenty of guys who
were you know super tough but at the
same time for whatever reason and look
you can look Josh Rosen did not play
with anywhere near the kind of talent
that that's--and Arnold had you know and
he took a pounding but I go back to
talking you know in season I work for
Fox and I do college football games and
we talked to a lot of coordinators and I
remember talking to coordinators
especially with one it was like we blitz
them 46 times we did not think he was
going to be very tough and by midway
through the game were like this you know
dude is really tough he was lighting us
up he kept getting back up and we were
going after him and you know I think
part of the thing with him is he comes
from a really really well off family you
know his on the mom side is from like
the Wharton Business School not that she
went there that that's the you know the
foundation of the family you know 100
200 years ago so there's that there's
also the idea was she came from he was a
competitive tennis player and he was an
elite tennis player who you know I mean
he was that was what he was doing when
he was
you know preteen until it was about 13
so when we think of tennis even though
you know drew brees was a really good
tennis player at one point when he was
younger we don't think of those guys as
tough guys and I do think some of the
stuff like I said some of the non-filter
things where he's popped off and said
some things that are maybe our big
picture things where you don't expect a
a college kid to be wading into those so
I think he's can be a little bit
misunderstood I think the challenge is
gonna be how does he come across in
these you know a little 15 minute speed
to hitting sit downs with the
quarterback coaches that he's gonna get
with and who's comfortable with him
because you his talent is fantastic and
I think that you know that'll probably
be overblown because so many people are
just gonna wade in and go oh I think I
know what this kids about I think you
know it's it's kind of a moving target a
little bit bruised Feldman on whose
podcast I appeared this week the audible
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
and I do want to talk to with you about
that in a second your Sports Illustrated
your si.com article let's unpack it a
little bit here who should I be looking
out for folks be looking out for this
weekend that we're not talking about
that are gonna shine up and show up and
shout out well one of them is Layton
Vander ash he was a former walk-on a
zero star recruit who was a good
basketball player and a quarterback in
high school from Idaho he really
blossomed on the field this past season
he was a dominant player against in the
bowl game and he made a ton of tackles
I'm told don't be surprised if he's jump
in close you know
upper 30s maybe even 40 inch vertical I
mean he's that kind of athlete he's had
to get physically stronger because like
I said he was a developmental guy you
know it's been a high school quarterback
but he's one I think will really shine
obviously say Quan Berkeley is a
ridiculous athlete I mean I think he'll
that people know about him you know
people know about Vito they'e
who's like could be 'don't re PO ask in
what he does at the combine but he's I
think he's a much better player in our
season you know we had Ohio State we had
Michigan lead a bunch of really good
teams Oklahoma
Rita van was by far the most impressive
defensive player we saw this season you
know on the field just I mean he throws
guys around he is an absolute beast
are those guys off the radar guy Jannard
avery is a linebacker from memphis you
know high school power lifter is he I
think he will really test really well I
don't think I'll test you know blow
people away ending up rising up into the
first or second round but I would put
him in that category of a guy who I
think is really gonna allow people you
know and then I tighten Mike kiseki he
doesn't block great but he's a former
volleyball player man he was great I
agree yeah he may jump 40 inches he may
jump 11 feet broad jump I mean he's
gonna do some ridiculous things
athletically and I think you know he's
not like I said he's not a great
blocking tight end but he is a stretch
the field guy and anybody who watched
the bay ten knows he was a big factor
for that offense getting downfield yeah
it's it's it's kind of been difficult
for me talking up Penn State guys as
much as I have would say qualm Park
clean this kid gets icky with thee he
was terrific I mean he could high point
like anybody else and we're gonna see
the tight ends out there on the field
with the quarterback Saturday on the NFL
Network and it does start off with
Barkley and the running back group on
Friday and in that podcast that I did
with you which I really enjoyed doing by
the way the audible you you also touched
on how the college basketball scandal
could eventually touch upon college
football would you mind telling me and
the listeners here how you think that
might actually play out yeah I just
think the added scrutiny of what's good
there's so much more attention on it I
think the difference with this with
college basketball as you have these you
know Street agents who are connected to
the actual agents and because they you
know there's less of a developmental
piece in this you know five star guy in
college basketball is probably going to
be you know a lottery pick caliber guy
whereas you know five star guys
for instance the year Rosen and Arnold
were coming out of high school
for a while the number one ranked
overall player in in all of college
football recruiting was a guy named
Ricky town you know he and he's been to
like four or five schools the point
being you know it's way more speculative
but having said all that you know
talking to coaches I talked to a coach
he spent a long time in the SEC and he
said it's dirtier now than it was 10 15
years ago
what have happened though is you have a
lot of people where they're boosters
they might be big boosters but they they
can the players are way more accessible
now when they're recruits
because of social media you can DM them
you can you see who you know anybody who
followed your favorite team you know you
follow the tight ends coach you know who
they are are recruiting because you see
who they're who they are kind of
following and then all the sudden it's
like those kids are out there they're
commodities and all these people want to
feel like they're invested in the
program and so they feel like
everybody's doing it which I think you
see the example of college basketball
where it feels like all these big
programs everybody is kind of tainted
and so I think that's the part where it
spreads out I think it's you know it
scares a lot of people who is talking to
who and I think the question is a
plausible deniability when it comes to
the actual head coach or people on down
of how dirty it really is well I mean
and and part of the conversation that
I'm hearing based off of again the
college basketball scandal that's
playing out in real time with football
is that the one-and-done in college
basketball that is front and center in
the conversation is put into the
spotlight the fact that kids have to
play three years after their high school
graduation to be eligible for the draft
and obviously the combine that's going
on this weekend and how that might be
something that should be revisited by
the NFL which says the reason why it's
there is because kids might not be ready
to compete with grown-ass men that go
down in the National Football League
thirty year old guys that will take your
head off because you think that they
think that you're taking food off of off
of your table off of their table where
do you stand on that subject no I think
we are talking about the one percent of
one percent now it's not to say kids
wouldn't wouldn't think you know there's
a lot of kids with whose heads are so
out of whack from the recruiting process
that they think and some of them you
know physically look kind of like they
would be NFL players I go back to if
they have this event called the opening
every year Nike brings in the top
hundred and eighty rated you know high
school recruits who are gonna be seniors
and it's on the Nike campus and in
Portland and you'll see a lot of
NFL players around like Aaron Rodgers
help you know show it up a thick you
know Desmond comes out there a lot guys
you know we're Nike guys come in and
there was a player who was the number
one ended up as the number one ranked
guy in that particular house and was a
defensive lineman from Florida who ended
up going on Auburn and I thought and me
and a couple other people including some
guys who were like NFL former NFL
players they thought he was an NFL
player walking around I mean he looked
the part he's been in a weight room
probably from the time he's in eighth
grade that he wasn't if he had been one
of those guys who've been like oh I'll
be a sub package guy and I'll do well in
the NFL I mean he's been kind of a bust
but physically he looks the part and
everybody was telling him how great he
was I mean you know you have guys like
this who physically look the part but
just mentally can they handle you know
it's a full-time job with grown ups and
you're trying to take their money that's
why I don't almost none of them I think
could handle it and I'm not saying they
couldn't stay around but they would need
to be coddled in ways that I just don't
think you know the NFL wants to deal
with that maybe after two years you may
have a handful of guys you can handle it
but the direct you know one and out I
mean we're talking about a fraction of
1% that are that I'd say I think are
like legit big-time college football
players they just it's just not
realistic
yeah I'm just even thinking right now
who in college football that's not
eligible would be able to be in this
combine right now there's a couple of
guys there's a guy at Clemson
Dexter Lawrence who's 65 340 he's the
same year Shawn Geary and I know that
you know people from the time who
referred him said he is going to be a
top 10 pick three years from now he is a
freaky athlete he is a berry he's a
pretty mature kid he's pretty grounded I
think if he was happening you know I
happened to be out at this point even
last year I think he would have been a
probably of the first three rounds there
would have been big question marks but I
mean he is rare I mean you take a guy
like Eddie Oliver who dominated college
football the true freshman at Houston
obviously at Houston different level you
know it's not a group of high program
you know he's a six one two hundred and
eight
five pound super app explosive kid who's
kind of in the mold of Aaron Donald I
don't know what would have been IBM
unity curious to ask you know you're
Daniel Jeremiah or Bucky or one of those
guys are may odd what they would have
think if somehow at Oliver at nineteen
could have come out what the NFL would
have thought of him because he is a
super explosive kid with a lot of gifts
and maybe the Aaron Donald bottle would
have been creating intrigue them but he
is such a rare exception to what I'm
talking about all the other four and
five star guys never mind all the
thousands of kids who signed you know on
signing day to go to play major college
football yeah I don't know if that topic
of discussion is going to come up during
the compound coverage that's why I'm
doing it that's why I'm doing it here
with you thanks for having me on your
podcast and there's always calling until
show Brett thanks for having me all
right you gots Bruce Feldman of si.com
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience